hi i'm shaquille o'neal i'm here in
atlanta georgia the place called monster
customs let me tell you what they're
doing
they're fixing up a van for meals on
wheels i'm hillary baker
and i'm the chief marketing officer at
meals on wheels atlanta
we ensure that no senior goes hungry
the real goal is so a senior can live by
themselves their business is not
struggling during the pandemic
it's actually booming but one of their
vehicles was messed up
so they called the general and shaq i
know some people monster customer we're
going to hook it up
so we started as a small soup kitchen
and just as
the communities changed we've changed
you know one out of four seniors in our
community face hunger
and that group is getting bigger and
bigger and as
we have especially in atlanta all this
expansion and growth these neighborhoods
are shrinking
and so these seniors are just being
squeezed out
the first case hit georgia on february
26th so right then we sort of mobilized
and decided that we were going to
front load meals to seniors because you
just didn't know what was coming around
the corner and we brought
chefs in that had been displaced by
coped so we brought in
chefs and their line crew just getting
anybody we can to make meals and to try
to just stay ahead of the unknown
no one lost their job here as a matter
of fact we hired people
and no one missed a meal last year we
delivered
over 600 000 meals today there's over
375 seniors on our can't wait list
we also do home repair we have a
refrigerated truck
we use that to deliver food to either
senior buildings big senior buildings
congregate meals
like cafeteria style or some senior
centers and there's opportunities we
miss out on
because we don't have refrigerated
trucks
where's jim what's up jim good to see
you my friend how you been
doing good doing good come on in so this
is the mills on wheels
for the meal on wheels uh run with the
custom wrap on it wanted to be able to
showcase everything that's being done to
help out everybody in atlanta
take a quick peek inside
[Music]
oh nice
keeps everything fresh that's awesome
this is nice bro
thank you i appreciate it thank you
where's she at i want to give her a hug
so when we build our new kitchen
um we hope that we'll be able to
eliminate this can't wait list
[Music]
i'm not turning around
hi hi i've heard a lot about meals on
wheels you want to show me around
yeah i'd love to show you okay
i have something for you
hope you like it i'm sure i'll like it
so we know during the covet
business has been up for you and one of
your vehicles is beat up
ah i wrapped it for you that is so
good my name is alicia she's the cro of
the gym
oh my goodness hi thank you so
much brandon did that brandon did that
oh my goodness we surprised you
unbelie that is beautiful and that just
really typifies who we're serving right
just happy people who just want they
just want to be fed
we know you need a break we want to give
you a break but there's more alicia
teller
so this is going to help you serve the
people in style
but we know you need substance and so
the general is donating fifteen thousand
dollars
by way of adopting a entire route right
so you can continue doing what you're
doing because
we appreciate it the community
appreciates thank you so much
i feel like i want to hug you i know i
know
i think this starts to continue to tell
our story
this community has to support this age
group they were here for us they built
this city and we have to be here for
them and it's just
it's spectacular i mean these are the
faces that
we're here for i really want to thank
the general because
people don't know how to help us there's
so many different ways to make an
impact and just by the truck it's life
changing
we're building what we think is the end
to senior hunger